bow it should buy a lv general lump it
slump it
my brothers don't eat crumpets man's
back and i'm
gassed obviously we're on lockdown yeah
carl boris tried to get involved and
mash up the system again
it's in me but anyway i'm here today i'm
going to be reacting to music
it's a new thing we're doing now with
stan that tv which you can see up there
you get me pick up man like i'm excited
still because i don't really react to
new music in it i don't
to be honest i'm always i'm looking
after the kids or i'm doing filming
you know what i mean so i don't really
have time to do these little things so
big up harry and standout tv
for bringing man on a little platform
where man can do the reaction thing you
get me so yeah
um i'm going to listen to you i'm going
to start off
with scraps daily doppy um that's a
grm thing obviously let me just get on
with it anyway i don't want to talk too
much let's just see how it goes
so let's see what scraps is saying
anyway big up scraps my dog
you know how the thing set already
brother
[Music]
saying dem visuals
[Music]
dark female yeah
[Music]
[Music]
i'm just grateful that i'm blessed i
don't ask why i took her out of a
spilled milk so i can't cry
there's one beef there in a state that i
can't afraid you could be a cello and
to ask t-bone how you want it done did i
i made the heat rise up
all you hear that's moving like he's in
the kitchen
man said different bits of meat rude boy
don't piss him off
just keep praying on my downfall like
they don't know the fire keeps burning
like a candle
[ __ ] trying to take me off my feet so
i've got to stay strapped
these flow's dirt that's just floating
on the beat you know
[Music]
in the bangle take a picture give a [ __ ]
about the
angle on my neck and let them dangle
the things mad heavy and their tangles
they're giving me a
explanation to my fan base hustle for
the future
[Applause]
is cold fab i've had enough why did i
even listen to my
rhythms i gotta go back i gotta go back
for this one
i say i should be i hear them talking
wicked on the net i know they would be
i just leave the internet business to
the purses
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i just told them thank you for your time
it's been amazing if they ever knew what
i accumulated daily
they probably would have re-evaluated
the figure they tried to pay me
i don't know
his own company record label like jay-z
get the [ __ ] out of it allow it just
don't leave me alone
the game's [ __ ] up now snitch is
getting glorified
six nine and then absolutely nice
head twice and said the sad times fake
[ __ ] are
real there's a bloodline
i can keep
[Music]
he's the coldest right now what
who's chatting to scratch right now
allow it
someone tried to scraps right now brad
did you just see what you hear what i
just heard
listen let me not even let the team run
no more i don't even want to air no one
knows blood
that was a madness blood that we got my
brother scraps in it i can't even
i don't even know what to think right
now blood i didn't even know he was
moving like that fam
then bars were mad he basically said one
of these bars was talking about
yeah this is just a little freestyle for
you blood the man they've got
mad blood these bars immense man's only
just done a little freestyle little
daily doppy
what's when you hear the album i'm
buying an album
for me if i was gonna rate this out of
ten this is a definite eight
big eight this is a strong eight you're
lucky ain't touching the knight thermite
should be a nine it's a nine
is that it was levels i don't care it
was levels i decided to change my eight
to a nine because i can
scraps nine the only reason why giving
it a straight 10
and he's missing one because i'm wetting
it that's the one he was missing